why do you not like libertarianism
so think about the far left in itself
right you think about people who are
communists you think about the ideology
of marxism and all of these ideologies
work through force they have to have a
revolution a cultural revolution maybe a
violent revolution whatever it is to get
what they want they have to
have a revolution they have to take
something over they have to convince a
class that they are lower so that they
can come and rise up when you have
libertarians then you now have a people
who say leave me alone against an
ideology that says we're going to take
over and so that is why i think that
america is the way that it is because
we've basically had libertarian like
liberal and libertarian people versus
the left and the left doesn't take no
for an answer where libertarians just
say okay i'll just leave it alone and so
when you have real conservatism or at
least an ideology that prioritizes
families and and and that sort of sense
then you actually have people pushing
back that's why people like desantis now
that's why a lot of real conservatives
like desantis that's why people like the
country of hungary because they're not
like this this just oh free market like
live and let live type of deal they say
no we are going to do things that are
going to actually benefit our people
we're going to be on the aggressive we
are going to attack instead of just the
the live and live type of art and i
don't mean to attack you or anything for
being a libertarian yeah just go for it
my thoughts about libertarianism that
ideology has made it so that now we have
these transit because we i'll say we
just looked at a thing today from the
washington post in 2017 they were
talking about confederate statues being
bad but the founding fathers good and
you go through all the different
timeline and now in 2022 they're coming
out and saying let's change the name of
george washington university and it's
like that's how their ideology works
this washington post saying let's change
george washington university but that's
how their ideology works because it has
to make people believe that there is a
revolution that has to be taken over for
anything to be changed whereas people
who say no let's just make it as free as
possible individualism will always get
ran over by the people who say we need a
revolution
okay i can like i can get behind part of
that and i agree with part of that at
this point and part of the reason i
built a podcast and i have certain
guests on is because i'm trying to push
back against it i completely agree it's
gone too far i probably
start well i was pretty disagreeable
like i was
arguing about feminism you know in grade
nine before it was cool
yeah um but
so i'm probably i think the part of
conservatism conservatism that
that i didn't
that didn't appeal to me was
there were elements of it that i just
wasn't interested in like let's say back
in 2013 when conservatism was more
conservative than it is now because it's
moved over um it was i was always you
know pro
make drugs legal type of thing which i
think a normal conservative would say no
there needs to be
like ban those
but guns are okay and i was like well
guns are also okay but like drugs are
okay and i think i was just i'm just
okay with more things
but the fight element i definitely agree
agree with you like what i i mean i i
left canada i talked about how
the way
covid was handled was ridiculous i
started talking about that i think in
june the first time right before i got
kova the first time like right away i
was like if you can't shut things down
though they can't do that like that's
not gonna go well um
but i see where you're coming from yeah
i'm sorry i like i don't know where i
stand at the moment yeah
i mean just an example of like
imagine someone says okay you have to go
fight someone to the death but you can
only use knives and so both of you walk
into the room you have a knife and then
the person who you're fighting brought a
gun and you say hey ref that's unfair
this person brought a gun and you're
yelling about how unfair it is at the
same time they shoot you and they and
they win the fight so we can yell about
how like unfair things are and say you
know we just want to be left alone and
follow the rules and be like this but
these people again again will take
advantage and they don't they don't live
by the same rules that you and i live by
so that's why we have to be on the
aggressive and say that you know like
like about talking about the the drugs
and the guns and things
it's like
you know when when you allow behavior
that is
bad for people in a society and this is
people are probably going to think i
sound fairly authoritarian but when you
allow degeneracy in some societies and
and you allow them to run rampant as
they kind of have in in america and the
west in many ways
then you will have a society that even
if they're left alone in their own homes
it bleeds out into the rest of the world
and so that's really what we've got in
in the west today
is that you let people do all these
things and say it's all okay and then it
bleeds out everywhere else and now again
you have this stuff with the kids and
it's really disgusting